before we get into the music before we
get to the tour I suppose
congratulations little baby boy a couple
of months now your babies do
yep that's very exciting how are you
feeling ah I feel great you know my
wife's feeling pretty good so we're uh
we're excited it's gonna be a cool to
see Liv be a big sister and uh bring a
new one to the family so yeah we're
excited is it the same kind of nerves
this time around is the first one or a
little bit maybe a little less you kind
of feel like you sort of got it you know
our lives only a year and a half so I
feel pretty fresh and it feels like we
can handle it would kind of you know not
as in the dark but uh yeah we feel
confident we're excited and has doing
honestly amazing walk in the park I feel
like through Instagram did you recently
go on a babymoon to Paris
oh we did yeah went out there for like
five days I've never been to Paris and
just want to experience that with her
and yeah Haley and I had a great time
yeah you said you were invited uh you
know I let them have their parents he
did say there's a lot of good shopping
that we would appreciate also when I
need to read him like my wardrobe I had
to Paris he's your Paris expertise right
yeah so is there an emergency plan
because you're gonna be on tour for a
couple of months your baby's due in
August what happens when you just have
to go that's a good question I don't
know I guess we're just gonna wing it
and see what happens hopefully have a
plane somewhere close by if it uh if it
goes down but uh but we'll see so we're
just gonna I guess cross that bridge
when we get there maybe your wife's
working on something right now hopefully
yeah so have it all covered I have a
feeling that or definitely want to be
there yeah yeah um well let's talk about
your new album can't say a country love
the title it's a nice little job to
critics who've said over the years that
you're not country enough and we've seen
this debate come up before with little
nods ex and his song so how do you
about that what's your take on that you
know that song for us you know we kind
of put the title out of the album and we
said that was going to be a song until
hearing it it's you know it's kind of a
bold statement but it's super
light-hearted the songs fun the songs
super relatable to a lot of people today
everyday person so we just felt like it
represented you know the record as a
whole there's a lot of lot of great
country songs on our record the way we
cut our record was a more traditional
Nashville way with the live band and
doing it that way and so yeah we don't
we're not really concerned with with
that it wasn't really an answer to
anybody we just felt like it'd be a good
little marketing tool and it just kind
of you know maids made the record so
yeah super proud of it we're just
thankful that SATA took us a couple
years to make and more formally we're
excited get out on tour and play some
new songs and fans are loving it so yeah
what's your favorite thing about going
on tour oh man probably just I don't
know getting to see the fans every night
getting to see the crowd and getting to
feel their energy in their excitement
and you know there's a cool family
environment out here on the road as well
that we you know when you get off the
road too long you really start to miss
everybody so it's fun to kind of see all
our band our crew and you know get to do
what we love and I think that's that's
kind of the bottom line we just love us
so much that kind of the all-around
experience yeah um meant to be one of my
favorite songs with you guys with bebe
Rexha have you ever thought about
working with her again and kind of
bringing you know maybe another magical
song out there yeah I mean I think so
baby's a great rider I don't I don't see
why we wouldn't right yeah you know and
see what happens that that obviously
meant to be wasn't playing it wasn't you
know we had no idea it was gonna happen
that way we were just writing a song you
know so yeah we love writing with bebe
and working with her and she's super
talented so yeah we definitely ride some
more with her is there an artist that
you were itching to work with ed Sheeran
yeah yeah that's a good one Bruno Mars
that'd be cool - that would be so you
yeah you need to get on insurance next
collaboration album
I know we missed the call this time we
love it he's a good he's a good guy we
got we got to write with him earlier
this year we got a couple songs that day
so got to keep writing you got to find
the right one that we can do together
yeah is it in terms of getting your
inspiration is it from certain people
that you're working with in writing with
or is it just everyday life I think both
you know we pull inspiration from all
different areas but we definitely pull a
lot of inspiration from our life and
from where we're at where we've been
where we want to go and it's also the
beautiful thing about co-writing and
working with other artists and writers
is just pull an inspiration from their
story to it as well so kind of a little
bit everything yeah
that's pretty exciting why do you think
you guys work so well together man we
always say we we just we work we feel
like it's it's ordained and it was kind
of uh kind of not did not take you to
church for a second but kind of God's
plan I think you know we both kind of
felt that calling and hey we need to
work together and let's see where this
thing goes and we just kind of hunkered
down went to work and it kind of needed
that we were doing the right thing and
the whole time it just felt like well
we're in the right place you know and so
uh so yeah we always kind of say it
feels really anointed if you will and
kind of ordained so we're really we feel
thankful and blessed for sure so you
break out sound crews came out almost
seven years ago hit the radio August
2012
yes does that look well to you that's
been some years it seems like forever
goes it seems like yesterday it's kind
of it's it's a weird time war kind of
kind of thing you know we played for so
many fans we've met so many fans we've
we've just been grind and we're so
thankful we've been inspired every every
show that we play everybody that we meet
you know every little bit of feedback we
get on our music or songs or people
cutting our songs and so we live a very
fulfilled life very creative life and
you know it's it's been a whirlwind so
it's just we just use all that so call
that up and use it for inspiration and
continue to try to put out the best
music we can is there anything you know
now that you wish you knew that
mm-hmm yeah probably a lot of stuff yeah
probably a lot stuff but I know now but
uh I needed advice trying to thank you
[ __ ] ah that's my Oprah question yeah
I think that's a good question I think I
tell my younger self not to be afraid to
dream big not that I was but you know at
the end of the day I don't know if we
could have ever envisioned our life
going where it went you know and where
it's going and I think you know we've
learned over the years that don't don't
put a don't put a limit on yourself you
know don't don't put a cap on it cuz the
kind of sky's the limit and that's
always what we've said and it's always
truly felt that way so yeah totally same
book that's right um what are you most
excited for fans and everyone who's on
tour to experience when it comes to this
album I know we just kind of rebuilt it
from the ground up the whole production
in the lines the whole vibe you know
we've got Dan and Shay Morgan wall and
Hardy Cain and Smith out kind of the
boys of summer tour if you will but
we're just excited that you know we had
our hand in and just kind of the whole
the whole design I mean we kind of said
what we wanted it to be and I don't want
to ruin it
I keep talking around it but no it's
it's it's a it's you know when fans show
up they they see the brand of the night
that they're gonna be under they see the
vibe and you know it's it's important
for us to feel comfortable onstage it's
even more more comfortable and portent
for our fans that feel comfortable and
feel like they're getting their money's
worth and and we put the time and effort
into it our band and crew and our whole
team everybody's been busting their
butts and making sure everything looks
and sounds great and feels right and so
we've all signed off we're ready to rock
and you know last year we hit the
festival circuit and do a little bit
different route come took off our little
headline to her and now that we're back
it just gets exciting it feels good to
be doing our thing how would you define
country music like what makes a country
song you know what I think that's kind
of a difficult question but I think if a
country person if the average good old
country guy country girl can relate to
the song
no matter
what the production kind of sounds like
it's probably a country song you know
and I think a lot of the general
population the normal the normal average
of the guys just like BK and I are the
people that you know work hard and play
hard and love hard and live you know
live hard I think I think if they can
relate to what you're talking about the
subject matter in the song that is
that's a country song
I don't you know it's really hard to
define you know but uh that's the
ongoing argument slash debate that's
been going on for decades and decades so
we're just you know we're thankful to be
a part of the conversation